welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm grace Helbig your host today we
have Jim Jefferies joining us he's a
hilarious Australian comedian that you
probably know his whole viral bit about
gun control but he's much more than that
he's got bits about porn and Schindler's
List now there's lots of things going on
in this episode and he is just a goddamn
treat I think I asked maybe two
questions this entire episode and you're
gonna hear a lot more than you probably
thought you'd hear about Jim Jefferies
on this episode about your deep enjoy
[Music]
thank you for being here thanks for
having me yeah are we starting now no
it's very casual
all right you don't mean I mean I'm the
furthest thing from Barbara Walters
that's ever existed homage to be weird
about it I don't feel weird or about me
no you're great are you so you've been
super busy the show is on hiatus first
uh yeah we go back we're back in two
weeks we're back into the office next
week
very exciting we did 20 episodes this
year and we did thirty last year but we
decided to do all the field pieces for
this year internationally so we had to
find time to film though yeah so you've
been traveling like crazy how is that
bin
that's all right what we do is we sort
of I plan gigs and then we just like I
go out I choose a continent I'll do like
Asia or the Europe or whatever Australia
and then what happens is I booked all
the gigs and then we find the cities
that I'm going to and see if there's
anything culturally or socially that we
is worth talking about okay what's wrong
with this city and it would be it would
be like I'd like to tell the audience
that we really think about it produced
before maybe you see an episode where
we're just doing a police ride-along
that means we didn't really find much on
that city all we've done that city
before so it's basically like the
Showbar rescue yeah where you find a
shitty bar and you're going and you find
a shitty City
every every city's got its own bit of
shitty have there been any standout
shitty cities beyond the rest the one
that I enjoyed the most was actually a
first ever field piece I really enjoyed
which we did a thing on on black Pete
okay in Holland you know about black
paint okay so I mean home they have
Christmas they don't call it Christmas
they call it Winter Fest or something
and they have it on like the 17th of
December I'm sure there's people here
that would correct the medes but it's
around there and they don't have Santa
Claus they have sent a Klaus which yes
you can't tell the difference okay he
rides on a horse instead of being other
thing anyways more of a Pope sort of
pointy hat but it still it's a got white
guy you know with a beard in a red suit
that gives you toys it's very and he has
an assistant called Black Pete okay and
black peas historically case what
happens is if you're a good child
Cinda clouds gives you a present if
you're a bad kid black Piet puts you in
a sack and takes you to Spain Spain yeah
there's something to with Christmas a
black pickup suspect he's black Pete's
just a bit meant to be like Santa
Clauses best friend but if you look a
little deeper back in the history books
he was a slave oh right and then he sort
of became his mate okay and now they're
not even acknowledging that they
couldn't chimney Pete and the reason
that he's all black is that he went
through the chimney before Santa Claus
into class this is how they've evolved
this yeah in Holland so it's very it's a
very it was it was it was a very weird
story for us because in what's arguably
the most progressive society in the
world when it comes to drugs and
prostitution human rights and a lot of
type of stuff and Freedoms yeah they do
blackface at Christmas yeah that's one
that slipped past a lot of people no not
just not just a couple of them Oh
thousands thousands of them do it down
the street with if you if you google
Black Pete this isn't something you're
making out and so that was like they
said you were there for when I was you
know I was just doing a gig in Amsterdam
and then we have to do a fill piece for
the pilot and that was the first thing
well what's weird about this country we
do we do Google for maybe 40 seconds
before we found out the Dutch are
obsessed with blackface it was really
and it's like so we know that it's wrong
to do it we as a society now we've
evolved to like okay we've all got it
now well not everyone's got it but we
all you know we all know that there's
something that they don't understand
they don't so I interviewed people in
blackface where that was like it's a
Christmas tradition it's fun it's for
the children and understand where you
were coming from at all no no no they
didn't get it at all no you guys had no
positive impact like it's very much and
other than that we've done you know some
cool field pieces we did in Asia and we
did we just did we just did like all the
Asian countries and we did like one that
was on the border of North Korea and we
went right to the border and we we
interviewed people who have escaped
North Korea and that was kind of
interesting it is talking to them about
their their schooling and stuff like
that and they could also speak very good
English and say I said why did they why
do they bother teaching you English if
you're not allowed to leave North Korea
why don't they both Dayton they go ah so
that when you kill an American you can
say something like you're you know so
you can see like happy fourth of July
[ __ ] or whatever they said are
you and they also believe that you will
had horns and Tails and [ __ ] like that
they also believe that Kim jong-un or
Kim jong-il did you know round of golf
in nineteen hits yeah I always thought
that was a little bit spun you know is
better than urban myth that they believe
these urban myths
Wow
so what's I mean how do you balance
being doing stand-up and then you're
doing these pieces that are really
impactful and they're far more serious
and serious sure I mean different like a
good perspective on it or like a
light-hearted ish some of them are a bit
like I said we do a lot of place
ride-alongs we got one coming up in the
next 10 episodes where I did a
ride-along and that cop in the car was
my brother they say yeah
my brother is an inspector in the Sydney
Police we're always hoping for some
crime to happen we hope something will
kick off yeah nothing happened so it
just became me and him sort of needling
each other about who mum like more and
yeah and I'll see how it turns out I
haven't seen the footage of it yet but I
hear it's very funny very sweet did you
I mean that's it so basically you just
got paid to spend time with your brother
yeah it was meant to be actually solving
crimes or whatever they do solving
crimes that's right how do your parents
feel then about the lifestyle choices
that you've taken my mother is that my
mother she was always very very strict
with me as a child and then you know I
talked so much about taking drugs and
one-night stands and stupid [ __ ] that
you talk about when you're in your 20s
doing stand-up and my my mother just and
she never said anything about it and I
and then she was like well I guess
you're just earning money and you're not
bothering us and so all the discipline
was to get me away from eventually okay
my mother and I'm not saying anything my
mother passed a couple of months ago and
my mother in the last sort of few years
of her life my father has just always
been a bit of a browbeaten sort of my
mother would yell at him and just go
every time he went to talk you go shut
up Gary you're being an idiot shut up
shut up like that right and the last
couple years I kick back a little bit
now this guy let him talk seventy-eight
years old if I can talk okay
anyway it was within two days of my
mother dying where we realized what a
vital role she played in the ecosystem
of our family because now my father's
unleashed I didn't know use a trump
supporter she was the one keeping it all
balled in and now he's just all on his
own just with all of his thoughts he
told me my girlfriend's British Indian
descent and and he said to me that
there's too many immigrants
in America and I was like you know I'm
an immigrant yeah my girlfriend's an
immigrant you guys all not you too you
know what I'm talking about
I'm one of the good immigrants he
reckons until he's on the show um well
he's coming out to Spain Christmas with
me now that my mom was passed he's got
nothing to do so begin me as I said to
him and said how about now I always used
to watch talking about with my on
podcast because she would listen today's
my father doesn't know how to turn on a
computer so I can say whatever I want to
hear this will never anyway he's coming
out at Christmas he didn't originally I
said when my mum passes it how about you
come out for Christmas and he goes ah
I've seen LA and I wait yeah I get but
you know who visit your grandson and
your son and you know you can come and
stay in my house and we'll do things and
and he has no no no I went there in the
70s would you like to spend Christmas in
[ __ ] Detroit
you haven't seen Detroit is the city the
thing is it's not the personal
relationships that you want scenery
changes does he probably changed since
the seventies in his mind not at all
it's at least like once upon a time in
Hollywood it all looks the same
we say no film I do those group I did
the little moments where I live near
Casa Vega so I did that yeah with some
of the restaurants that were there like
that's in the valley near an
ex-boyfriend
I relate to this movie I did see that
movie lots of feet lots of feet what was
all the feet I mean it's that little nun
thing that Quentin Tarantino has a foot
fetish and he knows that we all know
that he was a foot fetish and so I think
keep now purposely puts the feet in the
forefront yeah I didn't watch all those
whirling rumors about I had heard these
rumors in the past and so as soon as the
second pair of feet was in the focus
frame I was like this seems a little
weird Leigh personal you have to know
what happened with the Charles Manson
Manson murders the other issue I had
going into the movie you didn't know
much about I know about that I know what
those I know the murders but I'd had no
idea what this movie was about right and
so my boyfriend took me in he was just
like he loves Quinn Tarantino and then
it was like wait what is this
is this okay this is the tape murder
sweating well yeah I didn't know that
Manson lived on an old movie lot where
they did Western so that was climate but
my girlfriend didn't know any of it and
she turns to me afterwards and she goes
she goes did that all really happen I'm
like no no no that that didn't happen
and then I did do a little bit of her
how do you boy you've surely you've
heard about child Charles Manson but I
sometimes she makes me feel old because
I do that whole like I play a song I go
you know this is one of the Beatles
biggest songs yeah and then she goes
it's before my time that's not nice
before one time you can't use that as an
anger was before my time and if it is
you're gonna freak the [ __ ] out when you
hear about Hitler Pina Marner yeah and
so you guys are just like subconsciously
trying to make each other feel your age
yeah my ex my son's mother it was all is
was is older than me and my my
girlfriend now is younger than me and
they're sort of similar distances apart
each way okay and and my son my son was
sitting down in my with my
with my girlfriend and guys guys you
won't have to be my mum my son six all
right yes yes of course melon have to be
your mom daddy enough to be your your
daddy and then she's like she's like no
no no your father's not old enough to be
my dad hey you guys you guys what about
moms cuz your mom could technically be
my mother
and then he's mother comes to pick him
up and he comes up and he goes toys you
just said something that you were sir
you could be I think he's gonna grow up
and get into math it sounds like I don't
know I don't know Education Z strong
support of the moment oh no well he's
only six but you know the school brings
me in they go oh we have a problem with
him you can't he's not very good at
reading and I'm like oh my god 40 grand
a year that sounds like a you problem
she should be bringing you into my
office going this guy can't read also
audiobooks are huge now survive since
the Internet's really gone off where
we're doing everything I've stopped
reading books I used to read books all
the time yeah but I feel like I'm always
reading something I'm reading an article
or something yeah you're probably
reading like the equivalent of a book
internal terms like word count yeah like
the medium and the way that you're not
getting the the mental nourishment I
still do that whole 10 celebrities who
you never knew or blah blah blah
no it's not gonna shine it shows a
picture of somebody and I'm like ah
that's not like 10 celebrities you
didn't know her trans and I'm like that
is like a brief picture and Nicolas Cage
or something I didn't it's got nothing
to do with hoodwinked by gotcha
[Music]
too deep are you tired of unpredictable
haircolor results discover color and Co
the home hair color personalized just
for you by L'Oreal you'll get a free
consultation with an expert hair stylist
who will custom blend a salon quality
shade for your hair needs in your color
box you'll receive personalized
instructions and all the tools you need
for guaranteed results no matter your
hair color goal if it's blond if it's
red if it's brown if it's vivid it's if
it's passed out you can do it with
endless color possibilities will create
the one just right for you at color and
co.com
I am an absolute fan of insane
hair colors and this is the most secure
way to do it take the guesswork out of
at-home hair color with color and Co
personalized hair color by L'Oreal and
use the promo code grace at color and
co.com for $10 off your first order
that's the code grace at color and
co.com for $10 off your first order
what's your go-to social media if you I
don't go on social media anymore add
people running my social media I did I
didn't mine Instagram Instagram
I thought Twitter was full of horrible
yeah it always gave me anxiety and so
especially having a show we talked about
politics and being the anti-gun guy and
then other stuff I was like there's like
after the gun thing and I got so many
death threats and I was just like yeah
you know what [ __ ] this I can't and if
you have the choice to not put yourself
in those ways but then when you start
looking at social media I've really
stopped looking at the Internet at all
really yeah I just buy things on it now
yeah I buy it or ask it questions and
something is weird on my body yes yeah I
ask good questions where I don't know
something yeah yeah I do WebMD I panic
about things so shoulder at the moment I
think it's probably as a pinched nerve
but it could be a blood clot that's
about to kill me I can't say it and also
to left on its way you always get the
strike first right throughout a month
this is a very slow-moving
yeah it was like an 18 part miniseries
inside so I yeah I stopped with the case
when I'm doing the TV show we're
constantly watching the news yeah and
then when I haven't been doing that like
I'm a couple of school shootings behind
there's like just shooting what it's
like I was like what happened in Walmart
where and then a big and then once you
know you hear about the news and you've
heard about it like sort of three weeks
after it happened it doesn't sort of
feel as bad it's weird yeah and you hear
about in the moment but then it's
because you know it's all day it's not
new yeah no it's I mean Twitter for
better or worse has become kind of my
primary source for news information so
when I do try and spend time off of it I
feel like I'm missing out on like the
most up-to-date information about things
but what information do you need my
father can't work in computer and he's
just happy with these border control and
me fish getting sent in tubes over dams
and I would never have known what
happened I don't know the specifics of
it but apparently scientists and I guess
like people environmentalists I come up
with this tubular system so that trout
that I guess they're swimming upstream
in a future are in the patient it's
literally like do you remember banks
when you have had to pull through the
drive-through and you put your money in
the tube and it gets sent in - no that's
an American thing I loved it growing up
it was I've seen those things in the
movies where boot yeah like the Jetsons
had stuff like that yeah so this is
basically you put a trout in and it gets
like a potato gun like shot over the dam
and how do they know that these trout
wants to go over the day and that was
everyone's commentary on it but a brief
what if what if you're a trout and
you're in a family of traps and then you
know and you want to take your tail and
you're like kids always be mindful of
what got sucked up by this machine again
it looked so aggressive and so it also
looked like it was like an onion video
like it was fake like it looked like and
it's like this is what we've been
spending time developing the trick
streamed are they they the winter was a
sadness Salmons grab stream or the
trout's and the Salmons for the
migration migration so it's yeah is
supposed to expedite their migration I
guess we build a dams like can't no me
swim up yeah I'll tell you the Mexicans
you build a build a tube system for the
wall that would have been a great joke
I'm sure someone wrote the Mexican tube
sure they're by a hundred people that's
the big problem about like taking time
off of social media is that when you
come back all the jokes already taken
yeah that's the funny thing about like
people go oh that's my joke I can't
believe for the TV show because you have
like a production schedule do you ever
face that of people being like he used
my joke or like some sort of site
sometimes people have said something
about like somebody tweeting something
like on that so similar and you're like
we don't look at everyone's Twitter yeah
you don't watch other can meet with you
yeah like The Daily Show did did the
similar joke to us and they're there on
the timeslot after us I was just upset
that you don't none of you watch your
show like we're constantly watching
their showing the dailies already did a
piece on this yeah yeah like oh we can't
talk about it then there you know John
already do you think like people care
about me so little I don't know 100
staff members not one of you on your own
network would the senses weren't they
watching it or executive isn't any
oversee no no I'll just do an episode
where it's constant blatant copying of
everything less on Comedy Central when I
had a sitcom many years ago and and for
the season through we never got to said
we can season two but on season three I
had written a clip show episode you know
that one where they all get locked in a
basement they go oh that's just like the
time you show clips of who's ever said
but what I was going to do is all the
jokes and scenes that I had never gotten
into scripts I was going to act out all
of those and so like they were all new
fresh things
it's heaps of episodes of me and you
forced them to go back and have to drive
them crazy and [ __ ] they would have had
to watch it all again and then you get
to use those cool jokes that never fit
in with the other story that's genius
and you get to hijack all the view
counts on all the previous episode never
happened that'll never be seen by the
world still time you can do it on your
show now I'm working on it I'm working
on a sitcom at the moment yeah I can't
say the network or anything but I've got
a thing at the moment where I might be
doing a sitcom as well as the late-night
show which I bet this is like maybe the
fifth sitcom I've sold I'm like I sell
them and then one of them got my I've
had some I've had some ones that I just
like like like always gotten made and
you're like all right this is just a
dumb idea that I had in the is I had one
that almost like got what made that was
just the basic premise was I was the
original member from the Thunder from
Down Under the script is really funny
and then I look like this I I job and
they got rid of me
and so I do like a Jerry Maguire thing I
try to get the guys to come with me
yeah and then it's just like it was like
a Kenny Powers of stripping but it
really was just like I thought of it
maybe in the room or in the car ride
over I don't know that's concerning or
flattering
we were we were we were going to pilot
everything of that and then we we
actually mean the other rider we went to
the Thunder from Down Under for research
just to see what those shows look like
yeah I've never been it's never would be
saying that like sarcastically like no
no I've never been like I've that's my
kind of jam it's kind of like dumb stuff
in Vegas like that and curiosity to see
what it actually in time it was we were
not welcome in there meaning this but we
were suited right at the back and they
have a guard that sort of comes and he's
like hey you girls go and it's
Australian New Zealand lads and like hey
you got on you all right a lot of you
here on bachelorette parties and you
here with you mothers and your sisters
and your best friends but you know who's
not here yeah boyfriends and your
[ __ ] husband
like hey girls it's time for 50 shades
of g'day oh my okay Mountain suits you
know right and then like obviously it
starts off with Sun it's Australian it's
ac/dc have fun destruction the Thunder
from Down and uh and so they old denture
and then it's like now you're grabbing
cuz it's just like Anna Magic Mike it's
been sort of Granville we won't tell I
got a game I gotta give a bit of credit
domain I've got to give a little bit of
credit event when we're in strip clubs
it's probably because we're all sinister
bastards we all sort of sit back and
just a sort of ponder and look and it's
it's sort of like yeah we're sort of
like site like like wolves in the
shadows that I looking at a lamb lose
their [ __ ] you're not the [ __ ] fair
is softer sex your body more aggressive
just grabbing itself and like goes in
like bridal dresses with their mother
and their stepmother and it's like the
step like the the mother-in-law's like I
won't tell my son off yeah it's I mean
they become like cage fighters of
sexuality and that like yeah it was it
was what happened was at the end
everyone gets up and gets photos sits on
their laps and then I'd met all the lads
before and I'll tell her stuff and I
just took me shirt off and just stood in
the background although Friday and no no
I see no notice until like I just not
like that of course the body's not as
good but I'm extraordinary pale and just
like these guys are just fake tan or
bronze and you know all they do is all
they do is they work out yeah thanks to
hoids
yeah work out do this show try to show
you girl they're like in their mid-20s
and then they know they can only do it
for a few years and then another
Australian bloke comes in and guys who
make mix it there's got to be a spot a
prestigious career
prestigious career but yeah that's why I
thought what happens to those guys after
its own doesn't leave you with a good
skill
does it no yeah what uh what can you
offer to like you know a CPA don't you
think there are a comedy as well do you
think I have to me have some sense of
humor about it right cuz they're writing
fifty Shades of a good eye I mean I want
to meet the person that wrote that into
the script along ten seconds they have
nowhere they all come out like cavemen
just like like Tarzan with like like a
loincloth no this costume changes a
little and then there's a few blokes
that can do like a lot of back flips and
a very like like acrobatic yeah and then
there's a couple of bikes that I just
got good bodies mates with another bloke
Fiddler on the Roof shimmy see that's
what I would like if they turned it into
a musical musical elements like or a
stomp type element like if they can oh a
trash can lids
my father once had this idea I think
every man has had this idea just briefly
and then like God no that's stupid
he's like alright guys with porno and
stuff hey guys what you should do is
they should have a good movie like a
really good feeling like a normal
Academy award-winning film and then just
have like a porn scene in the middle
like when they have the sex when they
have the sex scene make it a hardcore
sex scene and then just the rest of the
movies good so you get a little bit of
porn but you also get a fine movie to
see something for everyone oh yeah like
that bit where Schindler was upset but
then he's Danny's wife was like cut me
you can't save them all and they had
they had some robust anal penetration
that's you know I guess I mean take it
to your next pitch meeting yeah you seem
to be on a roll that will actually be a
bit I've never said that before I could
be a bit you just weren't shafted yeah
good work sure it's funny I started I
started going through the the who are
the biggest villains in movie history
and I've decided that two of them rose
from Titanic what is the end not just
the end the fact that Billy Zane gets
such a bad rap in that film yeah he
takes her Christiana Cruise was for two
weeks the boat sank on the second day
yeah so she's lucky it sank because
because on the second night she's
[ __ ] a guy from economy in the cargo
bay in the like what was her plan for
the rest of the cruise are you gonna do
two weeks of just ducking and hiding
yeah you're stuck on that cruise ship
yeah you're stuck in the screen if you
want to get jacks now but get jacks
number but you leave the dance with the
guy you came with all right if you got
to stay the cruise out and go look call
me afterwards but he's giving me this
big diamond it'd be a bit rude and then
then she throws the diamond she has no
emotional connection to it she doesn't
like it yeah give it give it to your
granddaughter tell us what happened to
you something called the shippers say
your dreams and no and it's like we they
really just went where's the diamond and
then she talks for like three hours but
somewhere about the two-hour mark surely
they should have been able to disco we
could have done this over the phone
helicopter Doreen just because it seems
like she's pandering from telling them
that she sunk the ship she was riddled
with guilt went up to whoever liked the
watchtower or wherever the engine room
is like everyone's going down but I'll
save myself well it's it's okay so my
other one is Jenny from Forrest Gump oh
yeah there's a lot to mind there I
haven't seen it maybe in 20 years yeah
and I shot it to my son think it'd be a
fun film for a six-year-old a lot of sex
seems a lot of all right well you got a
fast-forward he's getting beaten up by
some guy here Oh Vox bored through that
and those are the bullies at the
beginning and Forrest Gump
what was their intention to kill him oh
yeah I forgot I haven't seen this movie
yeah well they're kids they're throwing
rocks at him rotting in their box and
then he's in this he's late things break
off and awkward
fast I could run like the wind right and
so he starts running really good and
then like later on in college they're in
a pickup truck same kids same kids now
they've grown up as well and they're
driving within like inches of forests
camped is running if he slows down in
any second he's dead and then like what
are they gonna do there was a local
simpleton that we used to believe we
were hoping to kill him and we succeeded
we didn't think you'd all be so angry
we've been on this mission since we were
nine years old and then Jenny just lays
it was never the bit Jenny just whenever
she needs him she comes into his life
and just swoops in and then Jamie's like
Tony's back again
she's like decides she doesn't leave him
she [ __ ] off and then she's like on
drugs he comes back to him for rehab for
a bit like she's not in a good yeah and
that was and then it gets her knocked up
she leaves again he's a billionaire he's
a billionaire he's a billionaire he's
invested in Apple here's the Bubba Gump
shrimp company and then she goes and
raised a child for five years it doesn't
let him know he has a kid she refuses
his right to fatherhood yeah for five
years and then when she gets the age she
goes oh [ __ ] it I'll go you see me
simpleton again she take the child away
and then when she needs the money when
she's dying bring him back again then
Wow yeah you had a tough childhood I'm
not taking that all into account okay
too much Jenny do some self-care Jenny
so it's very weird to me that I've
started writing a lot of comedy about
movies from the turn of the century
everyone watch those movies like myself
included and grew up I think this
nostalgia of like this is the most
beautiful movie it wins all these awards
look how far Scott was a wonderful man
big when you watch week I'm going
through big I had a moment where I lost
my goddamn mind watching big as an adult
because that's not okay big is super
pedophilic at the end
big she kisses him and then he has he
walks away goes from a man in a suit and
cuts to her looking sweet and lovingly
at him cuts back and it's an 11 year old
in a man suit just drinking also at one
stage he touches her breast and then but
also the idea that when he has sex he
goes back into the office and he's now a
man it's like sex gives you confidence
and he's there giving everyone a
high-five and he goes I'll have a coffee
and take that sign off my door turned
him into was the mother from that 70
show best friend comes to meeting for a
birthday parties like I can't hang out
with you I gotta go [ __ ] we go for so
much it's so much ok we're gonna take a
quick break
because now I like what other movies are
terrible did we get any questions I feel
like I just came in oh my god just some
we're gonna get you some 20 questions
after this no these are your you're
educating me and bringing up a lot of
very important cultural points that I
think I've gone over looks yeah your
water is very good here by the way oh
thank you freezing it woke me right back
with what I do deep if there is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more they will connect
you with a personal professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment you will get help at your
own time and at your own pace and
anything you share with them is
confidential it's so convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist and if for some reason if
you're not happy with your counselor
they can request a new one for you
anytime for no additional charge best of
all it is affordable and you guys get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so why not get
started today go to better help calm
slash grace fill out a questionnaire so
they can help
assess your needs and match you with a
counselor that you will love that's
better help calm such grace todaytix
isn't just for last-minute tickets you
can also buy tickets months in advance
whether you're feeling spontaneous or
just wanna browse you know you're
getting the best prices when you scoop
up tickets on the Today tix app today
checks is the easiest way to get theater
tickets at the best prices
all from your phone it's so convenient
and revolutionary that Forbes magazine
calls it the uber of Broadway tickets
get to know your own city in a different
way or find something to see while
you're traveling whether you want to see
a show that everyone's been talking
about or discover something completely
new today tickets offers tickets for
theater live comedy dance opera
immersive theatrical experiences and
more you never know what you'll find
I literally took three seconds and I
looked up they have tickets to Mean
Girls on Broadway for $59 I don't want
to get you revved up but that's a pretty
great deal there's something going on in
your city and you don't want to miss out
so go to today tix.com slash Grace and
use promo code grace to get $10 off your
first todaytix purchase that's promo
code grace at today tix.com t IX dot-com
slash grace for $10 off your first
purchase today tix.com slash grace
what's the difference like performing
overseas internationally I mean cuz
coming from Australia Australian
Australia and in Britain and America and
Canada are all very similar and then
yeah you know doing things like
performing in Holland is different
because their English is very very good
but sometimes there's a nuance where
they don't won't get a subtlety of a
joke but like sometimes a joke will just
die and they just assume it's their
fault you know and you go oh no I just
told it wrong and they're like god no
we're so dumb we didn't understand like
he's got the joke that doesn't work here
so we probably will have to listen to
the next one and enjoy that
both party is trying to impress the
other party I find I find probably the
best pound-for-pound audiences for mine
is the is the British yeah but also you
know Americans want you to do well right
really yeah the Americans won't they
whoop and cheer and they really want you
to do well mm-hmm and it strains are a
little bit standoffish she's like prove
it to me
what have you got what am I got and like
that and and the British people actually
want you to do badly and then
reluctantly clap when you do actually
they have a better time if their old is
Bui yeah they're just a crowd of
disapproving dad show them like your
college degree and then that goes like
like I had a mate who is who was my
opening act and they booed him to the
[Laughter]
chanting well the guy's time before and
then I'm like you think I know this guy
hooked him to open for me like you think
you think they think I'm gonna walk out
again you shy him lads I mean that must
be sad for him just like you're done
doable see just like all right I gotta
go yeah yeah that's right yeah have you
what was the best gig you've ever had if
there was I'm sure for different reasons
yeah there was like the first time I
sold out the bacon Theatre in New York
and the gig was really good and that
that felt great and the reason for that
was when I first got to America
strangely enough and there's a 3500 seat
theater yeah my first-ever spot was at
the Beacon Theater your first my first
my first gig in America was at Beacon
Theatre and we said what happened was
Denis Leary Denis Leary had
management is mine mm-hmm and they had
to get me work permits to come into the
country and so they had to have me on a
gig and so Denis Leary was having a
Denis Leary and Friends thing and all I
was doing was ten minutes but they got
me on this spot because I was booked
this gig I got the permits to come to
America so it was a bit of paperwork
fudging by my management and agents yeah
and so I remember thinking like god
that's a pretty amazing first gig to
have but I'm everything to sell this
place if you could sell this out you're
doing pretty good and then you know
seven years later I sold it out and I
was like all right that was like a
milestone thing yeah I mean it's a
beautiful theater it's a beautiful
theater and also it's that you know no
one loses that if you can make it there
you can make it anywhere mentality it's
in the song it's in the song and you go
up hearing that the whole time New York
guy and they are a huge New York fan is
an actual city I much prefer the East
the west coast of the East Coast [ __ ]
foliage and [ __ ] yeah hey the tri-state
area yep you bathe and the thing you
know guys like coming into Jersey Jersey
beautiful tree pollens and [ __ ] it's the
most depressing it's also a very silly
state because up in like the upper-left
corner of the state looks like the Shire
and then everything else looks bleak and
depressing and it's just I have one of
the guys who works in my shows from
Jersey and whenever the show's over he
goes I'm going back to Jersey for a
couple fights you buy that's you have to
pay me to be back there for couple weeks
it's very fun and sweet but 24 hours is
my max yeah I'm sure all your family is
seeing the gang why what's happened to
introduce them to West Coast um I
wouldn't it be cool if you guys came out
here I find it very odd about America
because these things like you're always
going on how to the land of the free and
all type of stuff and it's like them I
live in [ __ ] Michigan
yeah you have Hawaii is an option yeah
yeah I'd have to get on a plane anyway
there's any way with it like maybe
that's just the Australian in me but
yeah why on earth would you live where
there's snow
familiar oh it's horrible your car looks
like no and then you're shoveling yeah
then you're [ __ ] cold yeah and it's
like it's like I was in Montreal for the
festival so just a couple of months ago
mm-hmm and they had a heatwave where it
was hitting about 94 and because they're
Canadians they would just stay indoors
[Applause]
for the first time in Britain when it
hits like I still when he's like 25 like
80 odd or something like that yeah
it's an idea they have these heat
warnings and and then the Brits are all
just on their lunch break they're all
sitting out in the park
uh-huh like they're in suits like at
lunch and they just sit out the pocket
of stare and this is all right this is
living I enjoy their two weeks I
appreciate it all right questions okay
we're gonna go to Twitter questions in a
second but I'm gonna ask you the two
questions ask every single guest that's
on the podcast before we get into those
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
the cold spaghetti yet cold spaghetti
yeah well I don't know cold spaghetti is
that a gesture of friendship or kindness
always say something that does it sting
it's your own intention it can be um
demeaning it can be celebratory it can
be hateful I can be joyful I think I
think John Lennon okay I think I'd like
to throw because yeah it would be less
shocking than the bullets that killed
him
Ferris and also he you know he's going
up with Yoko he was into like modern
contemporary art he probably think was
some type of insulation performance
piece that I was doing any you know I
think John Lennon would just be like
yeah spaghetti I see where you're coming
from he would get it you have a
communicative been like the clearest
form of communication you could get I
just started I wouldn't say anything on
the bow gently
all right yeah then you're in the bed
with the most okay okay the other
question is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or close call but you can
only use three words or small phrases so
mine for example is college jogging
front lawn okay the six dite okay I'll
go you can do little chunks of like yeah
six tight okay black ties her house
[Laughter]
questions about but I hope she got a rug
cleaners I can't I recently just had one
I haven't had one in a while i I know we
go one to two years between drinks I got
a few that was the worst one because it
was in front of a person I I had I had
another one where I looked at a
restaurant where everyone the restaurant
staff got gastroenteritis we all got at
the same time yeah because
gastroenteritis is like food poisoning
that's contagious you know Scott like if
someone it's not the food it's a bug off
there is so many people not washing
their hands or whatever and and and the
chef had it and then the the boss made
him coming to work and then everyone who
touched the food he touched the food
everyone got it and so me and this other
waiter I was giving him a lift and we
were driving back and he started to
sweat and I was like along the freeway
and he's not like he's looking grain
great and then he just shot him
something he probably he [ __ ] himself
up we should buy that right so so he got
out he got out and he was sitting you
know like those metal railings those
guys concave where guardrails and it was
a drop off into our valley he was
sitting on the side
of this this were these are saying of
the air you're sitting up the edge of
the freeway and just like a busy the
Pacific Highway the main freeway in
Australia and so so all these cars are
going by and I'm like people are staring
and there was honking stuff alright and
I yelled at him for about a minute
before I just shut myself wage just
[ __ ] and then like that level of
calmness comes over you and you're like
well I can't fix this we're in too deep
now right I followed through in front of
my son the other day he was he was lying
and tell me we're watching a movie and
we were snuggle that me me boy we're
watching some cat 2 in a song that I
went through that I shot me so we walk
away and then and then we were
interviewing the next day we were we
were interviewing new nannies for like
when I go back to work he picked him up
from school and and I was like I was
like yeah if you could just make him
some dinner when he gets back online we
home around 6:30 you got to pick him up
at 4:00 and then and then hangs just
like this dad [ __ ] himself my right
where you're seated right now and she
got the job on the spot she is actually
the girl he got the job I can't wait for
hopefully a Hanks inevitable book that
he writes about growing up with you I
have in mind especially McCrory I have a
40-minute story the one that the girls
now select I don't know if I [ __ ] myself
more than anybody else but I definitely
can remember every single time so I mean
that's good I mean that's good the ones
that you can't remember the dangerous
dudes always remember when you shut
yourself at it and you go I did didn't I
I pushed that really deep deep down you
just pulled that right back up for me
thank you okay
let's get into some questions or the a
lot of questions came in that says like
what's one thing from Australia that you
would incorporate into America other
than gun control sausage rolls meat pies
I can't them is the same one thing
basically Australia's main cuisine is
meat wrapped in pastry
it's the perfect on-the-go hangover food
I love it I love a pie the football I
think they could take off at the base
boys and they're far superior sporting
food than a hotdog hotdog either but I
just very Pro pie what about hot pockets
is that not the same thing that's dress
up pastry do you want me to storm out
right now there was oh I lived in
Brooklyn for a little bit and there was
an Australian meat pie place that had
opened up like two years before I moved
and it was like a godsend I love it yeah
it was fantastic okay if you could
replace any lead actor on a TV show who
would you want to play replace any later
I knew I would still play the same
character I guess you would still play
the same character that's my assumption
oh I would have replaced Betty White and
Hot in Cleveland I don't know where it
goes I don't know I just I think we'll
keep this show going until Betty dies
that is in the end they went look we
have to stop at some stars financially
this doesn't make sense
like we want to have that one episode in
dedication but they never got to it yeah
I mean I think there's time for you to
do that yeah I think that'd be great
someone's asking any stories or topics
that you wanted to do on your FX show
but didn't get to because of its
cancellation oh yeah I told you early
about that one that was all the
different well there was one okay so
there was a storyline that we sort of
had picked now I had heard through the
grapevine a while ago this was going to
be that the first episode of the next
and this act that doesn't even know that
I was writing this episode about yeah I
heard my agent said that Dana Carvey was
in the office and he was doing an
impersonation of you and it was a
stearic or and it's like Dana Carvey so
good at impersonations that you're like
it's quite an order yeah and so and then
I saw Dana Carvey again like at The
Improv The Comedy Store or something
and then I went up to him I think he's
quite shy and he sort of just ducked
away when I was walking up to him cuz I
was like I want to hear the name
personally and so so we were thinking
that in the beginning of season three so
if you have much to say the show is
basically me and a friend and a guy in a
wheelchair and a few other disabled
people from the home and it all stemmed
from my best friend in college had a
brother with muscular dystrophy that we
used to take care of and so we used to
know all the helpers and the carers and
all type of stuff so anyway we had we
had a bike on a clinic daily he was very
funny in the show had a character called
Ronnie and Rodney was mentally
challenged person a better term to use
there and so anyway anyway so my idea
was that we were all going to be sitting
at home watching Dana cut like my
character got famous at the end of
season two because he got shot right
after the gun control thing and then we
were going to what be watching at home
and Dana Carvey on the TV was going to
be impersonating me right and we were
just gonna be like [ __ ] that guy we're
all coked up or whatever we're gonna go
we're gonna get angry at Dana Carvey
then what we went to we were gonna go
knock on his door and give him a piece
of our mind but then we chickened out we
decided we'd do the old gag where you
put a dog [ __ ] inside a bag and then you
like the back but it's really hard
nearly because everyone picks up their
dog [ __ ] you can't find him anyway so so
we get one of the other characters to do
a human [ __ ] into the bag and then we
get the mentally challenged person we go
you got to go up put the bag down like
the bag knock on the door and then come
back right and so we gave him these
instructions we thought that would be a
great bag and he goes up there you light
the bag and then he comes back but he
doesn't lock on the door and we burn
Dana Carvey house down and so that was
going to be the first episode to jump
off from and then move like I was going
to do like a charity gig to raise money
for Dana Carvey
yeah we had someone write and say ask
him how he works to incorporate the
developmentally challenged into comedy
without making them the punchline
regarding your show I remember tearing
up when season 1 ended alright it's very
sweet what it was I tell you what though
there is an agency that takes care of
disabled people
and they they had I don't know maybe 25
different actors okay and they only had
I think three or four carers because
they'd never had more than three or four
of them out on a job oh wow and so each
one needs a carer out there with them
like a union or whatever rules mm-hmm
and so we rang him up we were doing one
of the episodes in the home and I rang
him up and I said how many actors are
they gonna start 25 and I went we'll
take them all we only have four cares
like oh well if you keep quiet well you
won't [ __ ] tell him we'll come down
but then like me and me and the other
crew members and stuff like that we
weren't completely trained at a time it
was like herding cats we had people
wandering off into the bushes you know
in the end we did actually get pretty
good at it we've got pretty good at sort
of what everyone needed and you know how
to take care of people and stuff like
that we invited the parents under the
set a lot of the times and they were
happy to be carers and so that was maybe
for me the saddest thing was when I had
to tell Nick who played Ronnie that the
show was canceled that was the saddest
thing I felt worse about that then when
I heard it myself I mean amazing that it
had as long of a run as it did and that
you got the green light to make it but I
can understand that's got to be really
tough you know and it's like such a fun
momentum going
someone's to know who's your biggest
influence and comedy and how did you get
your start probably there's a guy could
Anthony Morgan in Australia that was
probably a biggest influence on me in
the sense that he was the comic when I
was growing up that I was like wow that
guy's really good none of you would have
heard of him he hardly does come any
morning sort of lives in a beach town in
Australia and I've never met him
yesterday no it's just as a kid I just
watch him on TV and I throw stuff and
and then but then George Carlin is
probably the best comic in my mind that
separately but I didn't really
experience him until I I've been doing
comedy for a couple years because in
Australia we didn't get HBO specials the
only two specials we ever saw with
delirious and raw and so anymore
was a big influence right so we got to
see delirious enroll because they were
cinematic releases so they were at the
video store but we didn't get we didn't
get the specials that aired on
television right I never got to us they
never made a special video of them they
just kept on earring I'm on HBO we did
so so my first experience with George
Carlin was he was Rufus on Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure Richard Richard
Richard Pryor was one of my favorite
actors I don't know it was a comedian is
like Richard Pryor in stir crazy in the
toy and all those [ __ ] movies you know
I liked all those Gene Wilder sort of
weird films that he did how did I get my
start
I'm same as every what do you know you
just go just keep on going down the
comedy clubs but what happened to me
wasn't universe you're saying musical
theater and I thought this isn't they
kept on kicking out I got full
scholarship rider studying musical
theater and I study musical theater at
Whopper in Western Australia okay and
with the same course that Hugh Jackman
did Wow
ages and they audition like two three
thousand people and they let in 20
people each year and it was a cool deal
because it was ten girls and ten boys
and eight of those boys were gay and
there was me and another heterosexual
bloke and then 10 girls who had been
dancing since they were five and yeah I
mean it was a fantastic place to be all
of a sudden like because when I was in
high school girls weren't attracted to
boys that were into singing and dancing
these guys are being revered and I'm
like god this is great yeah it's
fantastic God now yeah yeah and so so I
did that and then at the end of the
course
each year they sort of culled to people
and I knew I wasn't gonna make the next
cut I was going into year three so I'd
made a couple of cuts before that bit I
started doing stand-up comedy around
sort of Perth in you know person most
isolated city in the world a million
people and there's a two-hour drive to
anything yeah and there was a comic who
is like that stage I thought was a huge
famous kind of good Gary who and Gary
who had been on TV and everything and he
would came to our town to play and I
luckily got the open the opening spot in
front of him 50 bucks and I got the open
friendly anyway he took a shine to me
and he said well I'm going to go
do all these gold mining towns I'll pay
you $50 a gig and he goes and I'll buy
you a few beers along the way right and
I get on a bus yeah off we drive into
the lake right into like we're talking
rural like the outback yeah yeah and and
so I was like [ __ ] this opportunity is
too big to let up yeah I'm about to make
two hundred and fifty dollars and so I I
just didn't show up to universe anymore
I didn't tell my parents that I'd quit
and and I and then after that I sort of
just said to my parent I waved back to
sinning so I'm gonna be a comedian and I
I did that for about a year and then I
moved to England how did that mini tour
go it was great yeah it was great as
just getting [ __ ] up drunk I was like
20 it was like feels like a good time it
sounds like a young man's romantic like
cross-country adventure well there
wasn't there wasn't many girls to me
because we the towns who are going to
wear like gold mining towns yeah and so
there was I made into every one woman I
remember getting a one-night stand in
one of those cities and then like the
blokes are going did you hear he had sex
with her and I they don't been lining up
waiting she was the only single girl in
town chased out with pitchforks I was
the complete polar opposite experience
of your University someone to know
what's a movie that you've already seen
more than once but will gladly watch
through again you know a Star Wars I
always watch all the time and always the
Indiana Jones films I'm pretty cliché in
that aspect okay but like we think of
like something that's a bit more quirky
and not such an obvious answer like a
film that I watch all the time you know
the making of Star Wars is another one
is free on Amazon Prime they've just
done it it used to be a special feature
now it's free on Amazon Prime do you
watch TV I do i watch a lot of sitcoms
okay what's your go-to I sort of caught
in a little I I actually have a soft
spot for multicam sitcoms from the
eighties really like mash and cheers and
[ __ ] okay yeah I watch
I would cheese about once a couple
episodes awake and what's the office
quite a lot and I just find anything
that's sort of numbing that I can have a
little giggle to rather than and then
I'll have like a drama that I watched
with the girlfriend then we sit down and
we you know those started things but
like if in the morning I used to watch
like the whole and here we go here's how
the traffic is and what else is
happening Oh from the helicopter by like
that right yeah now like you figured I
don't need it now you don't really need
so so I just wake up and I put like an
episode of cheers on in the morning
better mood I'm sure for the day is
funny because the guy who plays cliff
Clavin in Cheers
oh it was in my sitcom playing the dad
and the only way that he got to play the
dad is because when I wrote the part I
kept on like doing his voice when we
were doing table reads and so and so
like I don't know why but at one stage I
went why don't we just ask him audition
it's like I didn't think what do we do
to ask him and he's like oh yeah great I
love to be in a sitcom so I got to hang
out with John Ratzenberger all the time
incidentally John that's a big has a lot
to do with my gun control routine oh
yeah yeah he's a he's a pro gang guy I
got nothing against pro-gun people it's
a different mindset to what I have and
I'm an anti-gun person because I grew up
in a society without guns and man and
then I but I was with him with Sandy
Hook happened and I was sitting next to
him and I remember him going oh if the
teachers hate guns these things wouldn't
happen but it's those liberals that
cause things like you know it's like you
know these things where he might be
right right and I might be wrong but I
don't think I am I think I'm right but
this is the whole thing about opinions
and it's um I used to I used to date a
girl who every time I got into a fight I
used to find this such a weird eye every
time I got into an argument with her she
would go oh the great Jim Jefferies he
always thinks he's right does it do oh
there's a problem with you you always
take your ID
like yes yes I always think I'm right I
might be wrong but by definition my
opinion is what I believe is correct I
may be wrong but I always think I'm
right I'm willing to be proven wrong
yeah you can prove me wrong but I'm
gonna start my argument believing that I
am correct do you say things that you
don't believe is this what you're saying
there's such a funny like yelling
argument to be like we weren't really
like that I agree it was just like
arguing about semantics of grammar oh
okay that's a really great thing to
never be able to resolve here you go
again being right there's an insecurity
flailing yikes
okay last question what takes your wig
off what does that mean Thanks if we go
like your wig get snatched like I'm
thing that what what grinds my gears I
mean I think alternatively like what
whales you so much like shocks you and I
guess it can be positive or negative but
I think it's mostly positive oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah like what makes you under
from Down Under
audience member level of crazy look I'm
a big Sokka for America's Got Talent
disabled person who all of a sudden is
good at music yeah clips all day like an
autistic guy comes out and we're like
huh you seen the one in the piano
yes I want to play a song and then it's
like George Susan Boyle we're like she's
ugly and she can sing who would have
thunk it I mean it's a shame that that's
our train of thought but we've been
trained since 80s movies that like when
someone has glasses on and then they do
the makeover and it's like they take it
off and it's the craziest like this like
she's not all that all those times where
they're like you try to make like a thin
girl with glasses in a pigtail
and you're like oh my god I can't figure
out what we're how will we even start
they go they go hey I can make any girl
in school good-looking no you can't make
like what are you pointed to 300-pound
morbidly obese person with a goiter
coming out of it like it's always like
take the glasses off give her beliefs
then she comes down the stairs and you
go you're a magician I do like a good
makeover the ice and love days I'm they
when they make someone over they're
startled try oh yeah I used to be
obsessed with like Jenny Jones those
like trash talk shows that like coming
on it like 3:00 p.m. in the afternoon
where it'd be like I was a dork and now
I'm hot and they'd have like their
biggest bully from high school like be
sitting on the stage ready ready for
like their reveal and then they walk
through this like superimposed photo of
themselves from high school with like a
mouth guard and everything they come out
and they don't look that great but they
look better and so it's the person not
having a reaction to them being like
good job and then the audience being
like okay so you wouldn't date me back
in high school but I was wondering no no
it was always your personality actually
found you quite cute you would just
annoy you just had a lot of hate in your
heart every guest that makes time for
being a refugee gets a personalized
fortune cookie from us to them I have
one of these right yeah this is my I can
tell well we've they're purchased from
the internet and then they are
upgraded no my daddy that's disgusting
and I find it
Trump is senior show and think your
accent is eighties Brooklyn we could
tell him you're Australian but we don't
want to confuse him more than he already
is about everything I had one the other
day that was racist I had a I had a
fortune cookie that opened up with
fortune cookie say yeah we don't have
that yeah I thought the fortune cookie
people may not be doing that for all
yeah so some people really to Trump Jim
this has been so fun thank you for
having me yeah where can people find
everything that you're up to and social
medias not yours I start people posting
on social media that was saying like the
Deitz and the gigs and I might be back
on there one day who knows yeah
and then Jim Jeffries calm and also fear
listening in Europe at the moment I got
a big ear pain to her coming up all
England and Ireland and Holland and
Scandinavia and Israel and Greece
also if you want to go to that that'll
be grand and then apart from that just
check out our being Boston coming up in
a couple of weeks and the show the show
is coming back in two Tuesday's time I
mean the exact data that is they should
know that all the 18 you had me stress
here because I look I'm about 12 pounds
heavier than my show I could make it by
mid-september but I'm not gonna make it
as only a weight that I know no one else
knows but there's like is like a
fighting weight I have to be yeah I get
it well now you have some time we got to
clarify that we're gonna make it yeah 19
get some [ __ ] cheese guy
amazing well thank you Jim so much we'll
see you guys next time real episode of
not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer and edited
by melissa Dumont's writing by diane
kang a production assistants by Katrina
Henning post-production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]